traffic snakes back for up to eight
kilometers drivers attempting to leave
Crimea on the remaining Lanes of the
Kirch Bridge the queue of cars at least
partly down to traffic limits along the
intact Lanes of the bridge trucks are
now forced to use ferries as teams
inspect the damage Saturday's explosion
destroyed one section of Road and spread
to rail cars Russia says some train
traffic has resumed but it's difficult
to verify footage released by Russian
State media while we're still waiting to
see the full impact uh you know Russia
clearly has to think twice about using
this bridge Russian President Vladimir
Putin says Ukraine is to blame for what
he calls a terror attack on the
structure it was built after Russia
annexed Crimea in 2014 that this bridge
was perhaps the Pinnacle of Russia's
symbolism for having control over Crimea
for for trying to force Ukraine in under
Russian domination and that symbol has
gone up literally in Smoke Ukraine has
not claimed responsibility theories
abound that Kiev may have used a
high-spec U.S missile or even a drone
boat like this one reportedly found in
Crimea last month the bridge is a key
Supply route for Russia's military
particularly as it looks to hold off
Ukrainian advances in Curson region with
Russian troops being pushed back there
are concerns about what Putin's reaction
will be he's recently made thinly veiled
threats about using nuclear weapons
but perhaps one indication was seen in
zaparisia Sunday more deaths in the
Ukrainian city after a missile attack on
a civilian area the second such attack
in three days Redmond Shannon Global
News London